how to get started with no money and no
income
this is a great question i got from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
sean who wrote in to say what can i do
or start with no money
and no gross income so sean
this is this is important because what
you're doing here is focusing on the
wrong things
you could start any business you don't
need money to start any business and i
hate it when entrepreneurs go out
and they start spending money don't
spend money until you have money
okay don't go out and get an office and
get inventory and get
get a website and get business cards you
don't need any of that to start a
company
you could start in any industry
part-time
on the side small without spending money
get close to your customers learn how
you can help them give them value
help them and you're going to make money
you want to make a lot of money quickly
it's going to be from providing a lot of
value and helping your customers
really quickly but don't focus on the
negatives
right you're sitting here saying i don't
have money i don't have an income
so i can't do anything instead focus on
the positive focus on what you're
passionate about
what excites you what makes sean wake up
every day
and live life right what are you excited
by find something that you
love doing and it helps people and then
i guarantee you
there's a simple way to start that
business without having to spend
any money it's possible believe
for those of you watching like the video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment
ask me a question below and click on my
face to subscribe to the channel see
more videos
thank you and i'll see you soon